وتعتبر دعوه الرئيس التركي اليوم نظيره
الروسي الى وقف اطلاق النار في اوكرانيا
الاحدث في سلسله دعوات صدرت طيله الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا يذكر باهمها ففي
السادس والعشرين من ابريل الماضي دعى
الامين العام للامم المتحده
الى وقف لاطلاق النار في اوكرانيا في اقرب
الاجال وفي الثالث عشر من مايو الماضي حتى
وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لاطلاق النار في اوكرانيا في مكالمه
هاتفيه مع وزير الدفاع الروسيه للجو وفي
اليوم نفسه جدد المستشار الالماني اولاف
شولدز في اتصال هاتفي مع الرئيس الروسي
دعوته لوقفه اطلاق النار في اوكرانيا وفي
الحادي والعشرين من سبتمبر الماضي دعت
الصين على لساني وزارتها الخارجيه الى وقف
اطلاق النار في اوكرانيا من خلال
المفاوضات والحلول التي تستجيب للمخاوف
الامنيه لجميع الاطراف وفي السابعه عشر من
نوفمبر الماضي دعا رئيس وزراء المجاري
فيكتور اوربان من العاصمه الصربيه بلغراد
الى وقف اطلاق النار في اوكرانيا لتنفيذ
مسماه
باللتفادي مسماه خطرا وشيكا